hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play surgeon
simulator 2013 the space update okay I'm
gonna try to do another one of these
surgeries because apparently I need more
stress in my life and I need to lose a
few years off of my full lifespan
hello again blarble large looks like it
wants me to do a cubed tran Grif fire I
don't know what that is but me and blob
over here you're just gonna have a
central moment so everyone will avert
your eyes from the camera while we just
handle me Can I grab your mouth can I
guess not a thing I can whoa what are
you trying to say to me we're trying to
save larb that hurts
oh you haven't even seen pain yet
Garbett whoops okay you're gonna take it
easy there buddy just for a little bit
you got taken nice and easy and we're
gonna take care of you okay the cube
Trent don't look at me like that
oh look at me like that million okay
anyway so what we need to do is we need
to get into there wait a minute I see a
little box with a glowy glowy blue
thingy is that what I need to do I think
that might be this thing over here so
again let me try to okay I'm just gonna
take this nice and easy stuff that I
have already known before which I know
that I can get ribs out with a saw I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna do anything to
mess this up this is gonna be the most
boring inane regular normal surgery
that's ever been done in the history of
video games surgeries just don't dick
around with me I'm not in the mood I've
been recording a lot of stuff with a lot
of people you're not gonna you're not
gonna do anything that would be
detrimental to my health just like what
I do is going to be very detrimental to
this guys he'll blar biz I think is what
I call them okay so anyway as we sliced
okay I think that's every single rib
that is ever existed I'm I don't think
I'll need this anymore so I'm just gonna
send that away so that I don't have to
listen to it at all okay whatever the
hell this is needs to go some sort of
weird freaky hand of bliss clear some of
the ribs out of here you know
like oh don't try to hold my hand there
oh oh you you want to you want to hold
my a you took my watch - son of a [ __ ]
quit hitting yourself
quit hitting yourself quit hitting
yourself quit hitting yourself quick
okay high five bro BAM alright face five
so enough [ __ ] around let's get into
it I need to very delicately cut the UH
I think that's the lung get your hand
out of the way there blob I'm trying to
point your fingers in me I'm not guilty
of nothing
okay so I managed to grab a scalpel as a
rat actually rather appropriately so
let's see if we can just very gently a
little bit against your arm out of the
way don't look at me like that I didn't
do anything to you okay
slicing slicing ever so gingerly ever
get out of here stop not doing that put
your hand down why did I have to pick
your hand up why do I always ruin
everything I just want this to be a nice
normal operation with
kill his fire Oh what was that what the
hell that was what that so that's what's
in here what the hell is that oh my god
I can still hear it oh my god go away
forever what is hurting him okay
whatever that was freaky I love those
tits too quick get in my life
holy crap okay there's an alien inside
the Ale okay I see all that's gone it's
kind of like the brain it's got a brain
stem here I'm assuming this is the only
cube thing and obviously that's named
ring for nerd cube who is an awesome
let's player yeah gotcha okay sorry I
cut your arm a little bit let's see if
we can just get that out of there but I
get it no I didn't get it zipped up
little bit about come on cooperate with
me Oh get out of his chest that's what
she said
is that oh oh okay I think I oh no oh my
god everything is backwards oh my god
everything is backwards everything oh my
god I don't know how I'm gonna be able
to do this okay I just need to oh my god
oh my god I've been turned into a
communist because everything is inverted
I need to smash open the cubed but very
gently oh my god sorry did a bit of a
hammer five Wow
oh my I can't handle this I how am I
gonna be able to swing this he's
bleeding out I just need to open this oh
my god oh you're getting a little close
for me there blarp get you son of a
[ __ ] I will destroy you and your entire
family and your entire planet if you
don't cooperate with me okay at least
the turning mechanic god damn it oh and
I smashed from the side maybe dammit I
can't get a good enough angle on it
maybe that maybe this will do oh go this
is so weird you can't see what's going
on but the controls have all gone
backwards like forward goes backwards
and goddamnit
son of a [ __ ] even aah
[ __ ] [ __ ] be right with me god damn it
okay this is obviously not the right
tool I'm not gonna use that oh my god
just go correctly this is why this is a
terrible one god damn it I can't
my brain is maybe I could use a laser to
cut open it I bet that won't work
I somehow imagine if I could just grab
it probably unleash some sort of hell
that I do not wish to unleash how am I
supposed how are these normally supposed
to be open not by lasers it seems God
that was stupid idea let's let that
laser a death just fly through the air
Oh God this is way harder okay everybody
shut up god damn it who's going so well
what the hell kind of a thing is to make
everything go backwards when is it gonna
end is it just forever come on I got my
whole face zapped and I can't reach that
god damn it god damn it how can I open
this can I use this drill aah aah
can't grab anything aah I'm gonna lose
my mind
god damn it oh this is what I didn't
need I was trying to get a nice
non-stressful gameplay here of me trying
to do it I shoulda known better planes
[ __ ] sturgeon I can't how did I crack
open there I grabbed his head and I just
wailed it around until he frickin did oh
my god god damn it
just go fricken there we go oh no oh no
where to go where to go where to go yeah
my face ohh oh god damn it right there
is that the broken one I don't know I
can't can I tell they look the same
where did it go where'd it go ha ha ha
damn it
okay I am NOT gonna do the cube
transmogrifier because that is a son of
a [ __ ] oh my god you [ __ ] you
I can't even there we go just hang on oh
my god it's still backwards
this is vaj
uh fu5 this is what this is gonna be BAM
in your face oh oh don't hit me don't
hit me doctor f everything about you
that is awful I don't want to do it I
don't want to do it god damn it okay
I'm getting out of here I'm kidding [ __ ]
that
god damn what kind of sick bastard would
do that to you what kind of sick more I
can't even do it when I do it normally
why don't you invert the controls
god damn ah ah man alright let's just do
this normally a gobble shaft was a
gobble shaft is it that thing is this
the gobble shaft the whatever the freaky
ass piece of crap that is bull
I don't know how am I supposed to know
okay this is a huge ball the nerd cube
thing and I don't know if these are I
don't know what the gobble shaft is but
the shaft is kind of in the middle so
that was in the middle I'm gonna assume
this what is if it's not I'm gonna be
yes
whoa oh now what I wanted to grab oh
here I thought I wanted to saw will
thank you mister drill you're not even
drilling you stupid [ __ ]
where'd the saw go the size rally
Oh mr. trowel oh do I want to you know
oh I know I don't
well how stupid am I goddamnit let's
just do this guy your saw okay this is
gonna cutting the ribs so long as I
don't get any of the other organs deadly
Oh
ah yeah zip zop zoo a bit about Zippy's
ah me that's one part of it out I'm just
gonna go ahead and get everything out
because why not
nothing should be in here anyway Boop
and allo be alright I think that cut
everything out God get out of my face
you drill bastard
alright well everybody you are using
Kyra time I don't have time for this
I don't have time to deal with that even
though that's annoyingly in the very
center of the screen why why would that
bad I want this one I don't what that
why would that just stick around in the
very center oh I can't grab it cuz it's
fricking Baker's in the way get out of
the way yeah okay alright got a scalp
low I got another one apparently I got a
two-for-one sale on scalpels and agony
one for you and a lot for me okay Bob
you think you're in pain
grab my tool here my baby my baby baby
favor baby
favor sigh did I scratch up your eye a
little bit you son of a [ __ ] yeah slice
slice and dice very easy very simple
easy breezy and beautiful is the name of
this game I'll bite oh I didn't notice
that thing tweets twitching and
screaming at me before so I don't know
why it suddenly started oh it's not
gonna say anything at this time maybe
because I stabbed it and it died okay
I'm just gonna assume that's the actual
gobble shaft what what oh really
everything's playing me for a fool
give me oh yeah hey yeah there we go
no come here come here I'm not gonna
lose you nickel loser you gobble shaft I
know you're the gobble shaft it makes
sense everything else made sense
come here damn it come here ah oh my
wrench you ever grab it there we go
there we go okay
yeah now you gotta go I'll get out of
the old one the old one who's floating
off how's it still in there get out of
there
ah you drill bastard you're always right
in my ear right in my ear why what is
that on it oh it's not not it oh come on
what the hell is the gavel shaft it
better not be that thing which is now
out of my rage it doesn't make any sense
things float around normally but when
they get over there they decide no we're
not gonna move an inch we're gonna stay
right there
I don't reach because I'm a son of a
[ __ ] and I hate markiplier you know
that error I've seen other people I've
God
Gabby you drill bastard get out of my
ear seriously why are you just not
moving from there it is not moving you
son of a [ __ ] i god damn get out of my
ear you're so annoying
Bob guys are hot out of my face I'm a
doctor don't tell me what to do you're
gonna die because you're bleeding out
but okay I've seen other people play
this game I've seen other people play
this game they do not have the problems
that I have they have normal mechanics
the developers hate me that's why I
don't have a part in here and the
developers hate me and they gave me a
buggy version go and I see if I care you
bastards one high-five into the grave
why I'm not even gonna do a [ __ ] you I
wanted this to be a more kong episode I
wanted it to be but as you can see I
don't get what I freaking want fudge if
it's if it's if it's the cubed I'm not
even gonna do it I'm not even gonna do
it if it's the cubed I'm not gonna do it
how I'll do the pewds ball again fudge
it god damn it developers hate me so
much
blarp you you did this to me let me just
pick your nose a gabigol what in the
world is AG a fickle God tell me what a
gala chol is you bastard - god damn it
okay deep breath I'm actually going to
use the star and I am actually going to
what the hell is that
god damn and I don't know what these
things are what is it gabigol a clavicle
is a bone let's take a vocal you're not
making any sense
I know it's named after like Gavin from
I don't know ragequit or something from
the roosterteeth I think is what that's
from but ah I don't know I don't care
okay okay okay
women play this game I'm not good enough
to have you goddamn part I didn't suffer
through enough rage god
well I suppose to me are nothing I'm a
nobody
so who care who gives an ass dad okay
alright this cut cut you right there cut
it cut it cut it
goddamnit okay you cut it alright fine
now this is going into oblivion f F F my
life and now for anything I was gonna
say F my a but no I don't want that okay
so now time to get douche McGillicuddy
over here blargh or whatever his name is
doctor God name is Bohr okay enough of
that enough going psycho bonkers crazy
let's actually do something here Oh what
it's not long enough yes well sure tried
I can't get in there
not long enough god damn it I grabbed it
incorrectly and this is not helpful ah
give me the long one that's also what
she said there we go this is a proper
hahaha this is the oh yes is the proper
brahma scalpel holding procedure
mm-hmm hitaka a koozie yeah that's what
I wanted to happen as definitely good
have it flying off into the abyss
because I know that everything
everything in this game is on a spring
load it's just gonna ready to burst out
of it like an alien
I just got it no I got that like 10
degree cut cut you bastard
tell you I'll do Christopher Walken I'll
do my greatest Christopher Walken
impression if you don't do this
aah what hey what I'm Christopher Walken
was I'm cutting an alien in half but
it's doing blah cut cut bastard just cut
oh god I unleashed it oh you're so
disturbing
oh yeah buggy it's coming right at the
camera good god yeah you better be the
oh no not you too
no god damn it that better not have been
the gavel if that was graphical I will
was that the gavel I don't even know it
was gagged bouche I grabbed it
whoa wait a minute I didn't cut it out
yet budge I don't know what the gavel is
maybe it would do some good I just
pushed that scalpel into his body I just
whipped your floor gang logging out
now I'm gonna make you eat it eat it
blorb eat it eat it larb do what I say
blorb here take two of these and call me
in the morning when you're less of a
giant dick to me I'm gonna beat you to
death with your own internal organs that
is what I'm gonna do you son of a [ __ ]
you do this to me every single time what
do I expect do I honestly expect God you
saw a bastard get out of my ear
get out of my ear it's right there ah
God everything about this game is
infuriating everything nothing I am
going to kill you
you want some laser eye surgery you son
of a [ __ ] about some tasty laser
desserts how about I fry up all your
inside so that you can never ever see
your alien family ever ever ever ever
again
you're gonna be like Taylor Swift and
that you're never ever ever gonna see
your family ever again you want a laser
five fudge everything about you I hope
you die a worse death than this in the
afterlife I hope that you go to meet
your maker I'm gonna break off all these
pieces oh really oh really yeah out of
here god damn it go play with it peers
ball are you oh this game so much I hate
it I hate this game I hate it I'm not
even gonna say the fake hate that I like
oh no I'm just saying I hate it cuz a
man no I [ __ ] hate this game is
stupid
it's a stupid premise I'll never play it
again
let me know if you want to see more in
the comments below yeah
right away